what's up Theo its Andrew from Texas
listening to you to past podcast and you
know you saying a lot of stuff about how
no if you choose to have kids maybe
that's on you if you ain't got food at
home and government I'm supposed to care
you I agree with that but at the same
time a lot of people are out of work
right now a lot of people don't have
getting a paycheck you know so it's like
if a lot of people will live in paycheck
to paycheck to begin with I know you
know what that's like and you know a lot
of times people don't have food for
their kids you know past paycheck to
paycheck and then and then now the
sudden yeah
they got no job so I think that's just
something to be mindful of when you got
a lot of listeners that uh you know kind
of rely on you for positive influence
and advice maybe just take it easy on
people a little bit right now a lot of
people are out of work and that's not
that fault you know it's not really
necessarily on them and when the
government shuts it down maybe it's on
the government to picture back up give
people some [ __ ] paychecks that's
right so game brother I appreciate the
Coleman I appreciate the constructive uh
you know not even criticism I wouldn't
call it I would just say I appreciate
your your your thoughts main yeah I
think what about what I was you know
this is from last episode I remember I
was talking about you know that it's
it's our responsibility like you're your
parent you're your children's government
that if something you know your kids
don't have something that's really and I
don't have children but it is you're
gonna be that your kids look at you as
their government you know yeah I don't
know if I was really saying that I got
you know and maybe I should not
clarified but I think I was saying more
that our government is just like a it's
just I just think this is a good time
for us to recognize that we we need to
be prepared
you know we need to be prepared for
stuff I mean this past week I went and
bought a bunch of water you know I went
and got extra canned goods I wanted got
extra things that I could have at home
to make sure that I'm prepared you know
the government's just kind of a system
it's just a you know it's something that
that we've created and yes like we you
know we look to them for support and for
like struck some you know to keep things
structured but when they start to break
down like you know we're going to be
left with ourselves if the government
breaks down completely
we're gonna be left with ourselves and I
think that's really scary to think I'm
sure it's way scary if you have children
you know because you grow you know we've
you've we've we've become accustomed to
a society that you know we're able to
you know we have a job because the job
exists because of the markets and the
capitalism and you know it's all and and
then that job gives us a paycheck and
we're able to provide for our families
but I think I was just saying more that
that that system is it's just a you know
it's a system that we've been really
blessed with here in America that we're
really fortunate to have and as scary as
it is that that that's that's just a
it's just a system and it's just a
structure and it's and it could it could
fall apart you know it could fall apart
and then at that point we're gonna be
responsible completely responsible for
ourselves so yeah I don't think I was
saying as much like oh you know like you
know like if you if you have to work
paycheck to paycheck right now that you
know that you're [ __ ] up or there's
anything wrong with you or you know like
it that that that's
Jesus Christ I don't know I why don't I
do something different for to make my
life okay but um I don't know man I
don't know talking about dude I don't
know I'm talking about well okay do not
know what I'm talking about
I'm just saying that we got it we got to
look out for ourselves you know we
really have to and it's probably really
scary if you have children but we have
to look out for ourselves we got to try
our best to and I think that this is a
reminder in a way that that there's a
whole other system that's going on
that's just a system of like existing
and and this makes that kind of like you
know we were in such this comfortable
hammock of
society that we live in of this
structure were really it really showed
you this how lucky we are to be able to
navigate within this kind of comfortable
structure where the where there are
programs for if we can't work or we
can't survive that there's programs in
place to help us but then also this kind
of perks up that other side of me that
that animal side that's like we'll what
if that goes away what if something
happens am I going to be able to take
care of myself do I have have I started
to think of what my plan would be and
maybe that kind of thing alone is just a
just too dark of a thought to really
present so but I hope you're doing well
man I hope you're taking care of you and
your kiddos out there it sounds like you
know that your family is one thing
that's first and foremost on your mind
and and I think that that's real
commendable man gang good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one